thank you thank you very much I just had
a great conversation with the leading
faith leaders of our country it went
extremely well we learned a lot I
learned a lot and we're working on some
things that are very interesting they're
very positive I thank them all for being
on the call and yesterday we unveiled
detailed guidelines for America's
governor's to initiate a phase safe and
gradual reopening of America that's
what's happening the guidelines provide
governor's with the fact driven and
science-based metrics they will need to
make the decisions that are right for
their own particular state to view the
guidelines you can go to the website at
white house.gov slash opening America so
that's white house.gov slash opening
America Treasury has sent out economic
relief payments to more than 80 million
Americans who have their direct deposit
information on file with the IRS and an
incredible success it has been if you
have not received your check please
visit irs.gov get my payment how about
that one IRS gov get my payment that way
the IRS can get you your payment in days
and they've done a fantastic job I have
to say and you won't have to wait for a
check in the mail I have some very good
news we sent out 80 million deposits and
less than 1% had even little problems a
couple had minor glitches but it's
substantially less than 1% so out of 80
million deposits less than 1% and that
gets corrected immediately so just
please do as they say you'll get that
very quickly very easily today I'm also
announcing that secretary Purdue who
happens to be right next to me handsome
man and the Department of Agriculture
will be implementing a 19
in dollar relief program for our great
farmers and ranchers as they cope with
the fallout of the global pandemic very
honored to be doing this our farmers
ranchers we have these are great people
great Americans never complain never
complain they just do what they have to
do the program will include direct
payments to farmers as well as mass
purchases of dairy meat and agricultural
produce to get that food to the people
in need the USDA will receive another 14
billion dollars in July that will have
funding to continue help are helping and
this will help our farmers and our
ranches and it's money well deserved so
not only were they targeted at one point
by China and that was over a period of
time and you saw that happening and they
never complained but that worked out
very well 12 billion dollars they got
and 16 billion dollars they got and now
it's 19 billion I'm just gonna ask
secretary Purdue to explain exactly how
we're going to handle it Thank You mr.
president you may remember earlier this
year you tweeted a message to our
farmers and ranchers that no matter
their circumstances you pledged to stand
behind them and while none of us could
ever have anticipated this type of
pandemic that we're currently in
I think today's announcement is proof
that you put our you have our farmers
backs and that you will continue to do
what it takes to support them and they
are very grateful we've heard a lot
recently all of you about our food
supply chain I think America now knows
that more than ever the wholesome foods
that our families depend upon and starts
with America's farmers and ranchers
America agriculture has been hard-hit
like most of America with the
coronavirus and President Trump is
standing with our farmers and all
Americans to make sure we all get
through this national emergency
so today thanks to your direction and
leadership mr. president USDA is
announcing the coronavirus food
assistance program
as you mentioned this new 19 billion
dollar program will take several
immediate actions to assist farmers
ranchers and consumers in response to
the Cova 19 national emergency the
program is really divided into two parts
one is a direct payment 16 billion
dollars in direct payments to farmers
ranchers and producers who've
experienced unprecedented losses during
this pandemic since we wanted to get the
payments out to producers as quickly as
possible we decided to use the funds and
the CCC the current funds of six and a
half million billion dollars combined
with the 19.5 of Kovan money rather than
wait for the replenishment of the CCC
funds in July based on industry
estimates of damage mr. president it is
becoming apparent that we'll need the
additional CCC funds as we continue to
track the economic losses secondly and
this is really important as well the
USDA will be purchasing three billion
dollars in fresh produce and dairy and
meat products to be distributed to
Americans in need through our food bank
networks as well as other community and
faith-based organizations having to dump
milk or plow under vegetables ready to
market is not only financially
distressing but it's heartbreaking as
well to those who produce them this
program will not only provide direct
financial relief to our farmers and
ranchers mr. president will allow for
the purchase and distribution of our
agricultural abundance in this country
to help our fellow Americans in need so
in recent weeks we've seen all of us
have seen the heroic patriotism of our
food supply chain workers and they've
shown day in and day out doing the work
for serve fellow Americans our farmers
have been in the fields planning and
doing what they do every spring to feed
the American people even with the
pandemic as we speak I want to thank you
mr. president for your unwavering
support they want to thank you for your
unwavering support for America's farmers
and ranchers and I want to commit to you
mr. president and to the American people
at USDA we'll do everything in our power
to implement this program as quickly and
as efficiently as possible to help our
farmers ranchers producers and kin
Zoomers during this great time of need
so thank you very much for having me
here today and god bless you
god Bless America god bless america
thank you so our great Secretary of
Agriculture was the governor of Georgia
for eight years and the only reason he
isn't still there frankly is that he was
term limited and I said let's get him
for agriculture do you've done a
fantastic job we want to thank you very
much eight years at Georgia we really
appreciate it
even as we prepare to rebuild our
economy America continues to wage
all-out medical war to defeat the
invisible enemy to date we have
conducted more than three point seven
eight million coronavirus tests by far
the most of any country it's not even
close in the hardest hit areas such as
New York and Louisiana we've also tested
more people per capita than South Korea
Singapore in every other country the
United States has the most robust
advanced an accurate testing system
anywhere in the world as of yesterday we
have distributed nearly six hundred and
sixty thousand abot IDs now that's a an
incredible tests called the ID now point
of care diagnostic tests and it's
fantastic so it's not one problem with
this business is it's a hot one till
about two days from now because we do
have a saliva test that just came out
and that can be self-administered and
it's said to be fantastic
I want to thank Abbott Laboratories they
have been incredible I want to thank
Roche they've likewise been incredible
over the last several days we've seen a
dramatic increase in the number of tests
conducted by hospitals and academic
institutions which have now performed
nearly 600,000 tests there's a
tremendous amount of unused capacity and
the states available for governor's to
tap we have tremendous unused capability
within those laboratories and I hope the
governor
are gonna be able to use them the
governor's are responsible for testing
and I hope they're going to be able to
use this tremendous amount of available
capacity that we have it's up to 1
million additional tests per week when
you think of that in the next few weeks
we'll be sending out 5.5 million testing
swabs to the state swabs can be done
easily by the governors themselves
mostly it's cotton it's not a big deal
you can get cotton easily but if they
can't get it we will take care of it
yesterday the FDA announced a new
collaboration with United Health Group
the Gates Foundation quanta j'en and
u.s. cotton to greatly expand the supply
of essential swabs including a new
polyester q-tip type swab for the corona
virus testing all of these actions will
help our testing capability continue to
grow dramatically so we're helping
people even with swabs we get
ventilators where now the the king of
ventilators we have hundreds of
thousands under construction we don't
need them ourselves the governor's are
in great shape if we do we have a great
stockpile that will immediately send to
the state in need but we've handled that
situation incredibly well I hope people
understand it I wish the media would get
the word out what we've done in
ventilators is amazing because they're
the big expensive and highly complex
we're speaking to other countries I
spoke to President of Mexico today great
gentleman and I told him that we are
going to be helping him out with
ventilators helping Mexico out and we'll
be helping some other countries too we
have a lot of very high level high
quality ventilators and they're here and
they're also being manufactured as we
speak following the announcement of our
reopening guidelines there have been
some very partisan voices in the median
politics who have spread false and
misleading information about our testing
capacity it's totally false and
misleading demonstrating a complete
failure to understand the enormous scope
of the testing
abilities that we've brought online and
we started really from Ground Zero we
started from really being very very
outdated and obsolete as a country from
the past and I will say this if they
didn't understand it it's just really
unfortunately I hate to say this because
we've been getting along very well but
it would be false reporting because they
understand the capability and it's going
to be up to the states to use that
capability the states have local points
where they can go a governor can call
the mayors and the mayor's can call
representatives and everybody everything
is perfect and that's the way it should
work and always should work will help
New York and all of the other states get
even better on their testing we have to
get even better and some people think a
little bit differently there are areas
where you have vast amounts of area
where you have very few people and
almost no people are infected and those
places will be looked upon differently
by different governors and I think you
can have a lot of news coming out about
that over the next few days I think
certain states are going to come online
and they're going to start the early
stages of the puzzle that we're putting
together and it's going to be together
sooner rather than later a lot of really
incredible things are happening
and at some point in the not-too-distant
future we're gonna have our country back
and it's gonna be I think really with
what we're doing on stimulus and helping
people keep their businesses together
and their lives together and their jobs
it's gonna be better than ever before I
hope so I really do the current
conversation is reminiscent of what
happened on ventilators you remember
that when requests were made far beyond
what was objectively needed we were
hearing from a certain state and we were
hearing from a lot that they needed far
more ventilators in one case they wanted
40,000 ventilators 40,000 it turned out
that they had plenty and they had a
number of about seven or eight thousand
and that was plenty we supplied them
with a lot
but that was the right number we we got
it just about right and if they did need
more we're ready to give more but I
think the surge seems to be over and
there are a lot of Governors just doing
a great job and they're working with us
but we're all working together the
research and development that we've done
at the federal level has been absolutely
incredible the media will be accepting
of these figures when they get to see
the end result I think they're going to
see it and I think they were already
seeing it that includes not only
ventilators but beds we built in most
cases far more than they even needed but
we wanted to err on the side of caution
this is what the governor's wanted they
wanted a certain amount in Louisiana I
spoke with the governor had a long talk
with him and I said you think you'll
need that final hospital and they
actually didn't need it we built a lot
of a lot of beds so I appreciate it from
the governor and we saved building a
hospital
in New York we did I think just a
spectacular job at the Javits Center and
even sending the ship up became we
brought it into covet but they didn't
they didn't really need it it didn't get
much use but it was there and ready
there wasn't supposed to be used for
that purpose we changed it into that
purpose and it was there ready willing
and able
same with Javits but they didn't quite
need the rooms that we the beds that we
we produced so we produced almost two
thousand nine hundred beds and I think
I'd rather tell you that we were over
prepared that we were than we were
underprepared and that was a good-faith
effort by New York I have to say that
the very good faith effort but it's nice
that we didn't need that instead of
needing and it was not very occupied but
it was ready to go still there should
something happen but I think they have
it under very good control as you'll
hear from our experts today we've
already built sufficient testing
capacity nationwide for states to begin
their reopening and I think you'll be
hearing a lot about reopening in the
coming weeks and months
most excitingly in the coming weeks I
think you're gonna see some very very
dramatic steps taken and very safely
we're putting safety first
we may be opening but we're putting
safety first and when you look at the
the numbers when you look at the
possible number of death deaths 2.2
million people and it could have very
well been that could have been more
frankly I've been looking at numbers
where it could have been higher than
that 2.2 million people dying if you
figure we lost 500,000 maybe six hundred
thousand of the Civil War 2.2 million
people a minimum if we did nothing would
have been one point six if you cut that
in half you talking about 800,000
900,000 a million people dying but we
did a lot of work and the people of this
country were incredible I have to say
and I think we're heading to the other
category and that would be if we if we
did work and if it was successful they
had between a hundred thousand and two
hundred and twenty thousand to two
hundred and forty thousand on the up
side and I think will be substantially
hopefully below the hundred number and I
think right now we're heading it
probably around sixty maybe sixty-five
thousand and one is too many I always
say it one is too many it's a horrible
thing that happened to our country
there's a horrible thing that happened
to one hundred and eighty four countries
all over the world is a horrible thing
and there was no reason for it and
should never ever happen again in a few
minutes you'll be hearing from dr.
Redfield dr. foul chichi dr. Burks and
Admiral guar to explain these facts in
in really great detail earlier this week
the FDA authorized two new antibody
tests which is a very exciting that will
determine if someone has been previously
infected with the virus bringing the
total to four authorized antibody tests
already this will help us assess the
number of cases that have been
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic and
support our efforts to get Americans
back to work by
showing us who might have developed the
wonderful beautiful immunity ultimate
victory in this war will be made
possible by America's scientific
brilliance there is nothing like us
there is nobody like us not even close I
wish I could tell you stories what other
countries even powerful countries say to
me the leaders and they say it quietly
and they say it off the record but they
have great respect for what we can do
and our country is at a point a few
weeks ago think of it four or five weeks
ago we were at a level that nobody had
ever attained the best job numbers we've
ever had the best economy we've ever had
every company virtually was doing better
business than ever before the stock
market was at all-time highs and then
one day they said you got to close it up
and we did the right thing
we saved maybe millions of lives by
doing it the way we did it but we're
paying a price but that price is very
unimportant compared to the number of
lives we're talking about the NIH and
others are conducting clinical trials of
35 different therapies and treatments
therapies being so exciting to me
because that's really like if something
happens you're gonna get better
reasonably quickly and without such a
horrible deal as some people have to go
through to that end today NIH announced
that it is launching a public-private
partnership with more than a dozen bio
pharmaceutical companies their HHS FDA
CDC and the European Medicines Agency
they're all working together we're
working together with a lot of other
countries the partnership will marshal
and coordinate the vast resources
knowledge assets and authorities of more
than a dozen organizations and agencies
to accelerate development of the most
promising therapies and vaccines the
vaccines are coming along really really
well Johnson & Johnson is very well
advanced one thing is they have to
having great great six
but we have to test them and it takes a
long period of time it takes probably
over a year unfortunately but therapies
like wise are coming along very very
well therapy's our immediate when we get
that that'll be a big day
we're also equipping our medical
warriors on the front lines in total we
have the project air bridge and the air
bridge has been incredible the national
strategic stockpile and every other
channel the federal government is
deployed if you think about this forty
four point five million n95 masks nearly
five hundred and twenty four million
loved sixty three point five million
surgical masks and more than 10 million
gowns and we have 500 million masks
coming in very soon between
manufacturing and orders 500 million
masks the last few months have been
among the most challenging times in the
history of our nation this invisible
enemy is tough and it's smart and it's
vicious
but every day we're getting closer to
the future that we all have been waiting
for I talked about the light at the end
of the tunnel we are getting very very
close to seeing that light shine very
brightly at the end of that tunnel and
it's happening and I want to thank
everybody in the room I want to thank I
actually want to thank some of the media
we've had some fair coverage some really
fair coverage and I appreciate it what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
introduce a great vice president Mike
Pence and he's going to take over for a
little while I'm gonna leave and I'm
coming right back and we'll take some
questions they're going to go over our
tremendous testing capabilities and
again I'll be right back thank you thank
you very much
Thank You mr. president and good
afternoon all today as the president
just reflected it remains a challenging
time in the life of our nation because
of the extraordinary efforts of the
American people because of the strong
partnership the federal government has
forged with states across the country
we're making progress America despite
the the tragic loss of more than 36,000
Americans according to our best data
reporting this morning we continue to
see new cases low and steady on the west
coast and we continue to see cases and
hospitalizations declining in the
Greater New York City area in New
Orleans and Detroit and elsewhere this
is a tribute first and foremost to our
our health care doctors nurses all of
those working on the front lines but
it's also a great tribute to the
American people who have put into
practice the social distancing the
guidelines the guidance of state and
local officials and we we hope that
every American is encouraged by the
steady progress that we are making we're
continuing to bring at the president's
direction of the full resources of the
federal government to bear today the
president approved a major disaster
declaration for American Samoa and now
all 50 states and all territories are
under major disaster declarations for
the first time in American history at
this present moment 33,000 National
Guardsmen are on duty 5,500 active duty
military personnel had been deployed to
nine states including 716 medical
professionals doctors and nurses who
deployed out 14 different hospitals
today among those were 10 hospitals in
New York City and military personnel
were also serving today in hospitals in
Connecticut Texas Louisiana
and New Jersey yesterday as the
president reflected we unveiled the
president's guidelines for opening up
America again there were two parts at
the beginning of those guidelines first
the criteria that we hope will guide
governor's in their decisions about
reopening their states on either a
statewide level or a county level and
then also we outlined what we believe
would be the most important state
responsibilities to have in place before
moving into a reopening plan for Phase
one the president's guidelines you'll
recall advised that states that have a
downward trajectory in cases over a 14
day period of time and ensure that they
have proper capacity in their health
care facilities could move to phase one
with the easing of some of the social
distancing and the criteria that have
been in place but for states that meet
the criteria we outlined specific
responsibilities protecting workers in
critical industries particularly
protecting the most vulnerable those who
live and work in senior care facilities
and we also encouraged States to have a
plan for testing symptomatic individuals
and ensuring testing to our most
vulnerable populations as the president
has made clear governors will decide the
time and manner that their states reopen
and we will look to support them in that
effort but as we assured the American
people yesterday the president's
Direction our administration will
continue to work with governors across
the country to ensure that they have the
equipment and the supplies and the
testing resources to reopen safely and
responsibly on the subject of supplies
today we issued a letter to our nation's
governor summarizing all the medical
equipment and supplies that have been
distributed to their state from FEMA
between the first of this month and
April 14th through project air bridge
and through the commercial supply
network we'll be speaking with our
nation's governor's on Monday and
detailing that in
Meishan at that time as of April 16th as
the president reflected briefly FEMA has
coordinated the delivery of millions of
pieces of medical equipment including 44
million n95 respirators 63 million
surgical masks more than 10,000
ventilators and of course deployed more
than 8,600 federal federal medical
station beds on the subject of testing
resources we're going to take some time
to speak about our administration's
approach in partnership with States to
continue to expand testing across the
country at this briefing but from the
very outset of this epidemic
a president Trump made efforts to
essentially reinvent testing in America
the traditional testing in this country
that takes place at CDC or at state labs
was designed for basically the kind of
diagnostic testing that is routinely
required but the president early on in
this effort brought together the leading
commercial labs in America we forged a
public and private partnership and six
weeks ago we had performed some 25,000
tests and at this day we have performed
3.7 million tests we believe that labs
and hospitals are now performing more
than a hundred and twenty thousand tests
a day and we've actually stood up a team
from Walter Reed under the direction of
dr. deborah birx that is working around
the clock to identify additional testing
capacity across the country we believe
that states could actually more than
double the amount of daily testing that
is happening today by simply activating
all of the labs and dr. Burks will
detail some of those resources today and
we'll be going over those very
specifically with governor's on Monday
we've also been promoting the
development of new and innovative tests
we all know about the 15-minute avid
test but the FDA is currently working on
an antibody test that literally could
add 20 million new tests to our supply
even before the end of April I want to
assure the American people that we're
going to continue to work with your
governors and with your state health
officials
to scale testing in the days ahead but
as you'll hear from all of our experts
tonight
our best scientist and health experts
assess that states today have enough
tests to implement the criteria of phase
one if they choose to do so let me say
that again the given the given the
guidance in the the president's new
guidelines for opening up America again
states that meet the criteria for going
into phase one and then are preparing
the testing that is contemplated by
going to phase one our best scientists
and health experts assess that today we
have a sufficient amount of testing to
meet the requirements of a phase one
reopening if state governors should
choose to do that and you'll hear more
detail on that in just a moment at the
president's direction we're going to be
presenting an outline of our approach to
testing in partnership with States
during this briefing our approach will
continue to be locally executed state
managed and federally supported dr.
Falchi will give us a brief introduction
to the overall approach to testing that
is contemplated to deal with the corona
virus dr. Redfield of CDC will describe
our plan to mobilize CDC officials in
all 50 states to specifically monitor
coronavirus corona virus incidents that
occur in every state in the Union of
course dr. deborah birx will describe
not only our tests but also the current
capability and the capability that we
could expand to very readily and Admiral
gerar of the US Public Health Service
will summarize our approach but I want
to assure the American people that at
the president's direction we are going
to continue to work every single day to
make sure that our states and
communities have the testing they need
to reopen at the time and manner of
their choosing and we're going to work
every day to make sure our states have
the resources and the supplies to reopen
their states and reopen a mirror
in a safe and responsible way with that
dr. pouchy thank you very much mr. vice
president so as the vice president said
I'm going to give you a brief
introduction to kind of answer the
question that we've been asked a lot in
fact we had a very productive
teleconference with the Senate
Democratic caucus just a few hours ago
and they asked a number of questions
which were really reasonable questions
questions that are on the mind of a lot
of different people and one of them was
the question that was just posed a
moment ago is are there enough tests to
allow us to be able to go through this
first phase in a way that is protective
of the health and the safety of the
American people so I just want to spend
a couple of minutes clarifying a few
things and maybe providing some
information on a broad 40,000 foot which
you'll hear some of the more granular
details from my colleagues who will be
following me I I think they they asked
me to give the 40,000 foot one because
I'm not a testing person I didn't run a
testing lab but I'm part of a team that
is looking at this of how we can best
make sure this happens in the right way
so first of all let me say something
that we said before and I apologize if
I'm repeating things that you already
know but I think in some respects it's
important to do that so that people have
clarity and what we're talking about
there are two general types of tests
even though within each general type
there are different subgroups one of
them is to actually test for the
infection is a person infected the other
and I'll get back to that in it in a
second the other is to test as we just
mentioned if someone has been infected
usually someone has been infected who
has recovered and as I'll get to in a
moment that you could assume although we
need to do some more work on that that
that person is actually protected
against subsequent exposure and
infection with an identical organism so
what are some of the
pluses and minuses of each because the
pluses and minuses are really going to
impact how we best use the test and how
the test actually should be used so
let's take the test for whether or not
you're infected the test of whether or
not you're infected is a test that right
now is a call to nucleic acid test it's
not an easy test to do there are some
that are more rapid there are some that
have a high throughput there are
different groups within that the good
news about that is that it's a sensitive
and specific test so that if you're
infected you know you're infected so
that as I'll get to in a moment if you
need to do something with that get that
person put them in care take care of
them get them out of circulation that's
important the part about that that I
think is often misunderstood is that if
you get a test today like I did today
it's negative if you get a test today
that does not mean that tomorrow or the
next day or the next day or the next day
as you get exposed perhaps from someone
who may not even know they're infected
that that means that I'm negative which
means if you take that to its extreme in
order to be really sure you would almost
have to test somebody either every day
or every other day or every week or what
it is to be absolutely certain that's an
issue now the the problem that that I
about we're not when I try and compare
this to other situations with what
testing means to you
I'm as think most people know have been
involved in HIV AIDS for 38 years 39
years from the very first week of HIV so
that's what I do if you get a test for
HIV and you are negative and you do not
practice any risk behaviors you can be
guaranteed that next month six months
one year from now you will be
negative if you don't have a risk
behavior so there's a big difference
there about what testing actually means
so the point I think you're getting is
that although there is clearly a place
for needing to test somebody for a given
reason a test means you're negative now
now the other test is an antibody test a
test that tells you in fact that you've
been infected that's really good you're
gonna hear about that a bit about that
from my colleagues in a moment because
that will give you a broader view of two
things one what the penetrance of the
infection had been and number two you
can make an assumption though we still
need to prove that i mean we are
assuming that if you're infected and you
have antibody you're protected I don't
think that's a reasonable assumption
based on our experience with other
viruses but what we want to make sure
that we know and these are some of the
challenges
what is the titer that is protective how
long is the protection is it one month
is it three months is it six months it's
a year so we need to be humble and
modest that we don't know everything
about it
but it really is an important test the
other thing is the difference between
testing and monitoring out there what's
out there the difference between what we
really needed for for phase 1 is to be
able to identify isolate contact trace a
very important part of when you're
putting pulling back gradually and
slowly on the mitigation and you have
people who might be infected you want to
know they're infected you want to put
them in care that is something that we
absolutely need to do but there are
other ways we I want to make sure people
understand that not to underestimate the
importance of testing testing is a part
an important part of a multi-faceted way
that we are going to control and
ultimately end this outbreak so please
don't anyone interpretive that I'm down
peasant testing but the emphasis that
we've been hearing is essentially
testing is everything and it isn't it's
the kinds of things that we've been
doing the mitigation strategies that are
important part of that
now just a couple of things before I
hand it over to my colleagues no doubt
no doubt that early on we had a problem
I have publicly said that we had a
problem early on there was a problem
that had to be corrected and it was
corrected it was a problem that was a
technical problem from within that was
corrected and it was an issue of
embracing the way we have now and should
have the private sector who clearly has
the capability of making in providing
tests at the level that we will need
them for any of the things that I've
just spoken about so having said that
right now I totally understand and I
want a lot alone my colleagues
understand that although we say there
are X number of tests out there and
you're gonna hear from Admiral Jarrah
about that the fact is there have been
and still are situations that are
correctable and will be corrected and
some of which have been corrected I know
I get on the phone a lot with my
colleagues because believe it or not
some long time ago I was where they are
in the hospitals in the emergency room
looking at very sick individuals that
you need to take care of and I know what
it means when someone tells you hey you
have what you need and you look around
and you say well maybe you think I have
what I need but I don't really have what
I need so we have to figure out how do
we close that gap and there are a lot of
things that I think we've learned and
that we are correcting and going to
correct namely you have a situation
where tests are needed and appropriate
and either people have found there's no
tests or there's no reagents or there's
no swabs or a person needed a test and
we're told that there was a restriction
they couldn't get a test these are all
the things that I'm telling you you
already know because you've heard them
so right now or there's a delay of five
to seven days and what does that mean if
you want to
if you want to get somebody out of
circulation we understand that that
existed but upon careful examination
what you are going to hear that many of
those have been already corrected and
other of those will be corrected because
what I think people don't appreciate
through no fault of their own is that
this is that there are two issues
there's supply and demand and if you
have a supply that can meet the demand
but the supply is not connected to
demand then supply demand falls apart
what do I mean by that I mean there is
existing capacity that we have that for
one reason or other maybe has not been
fully communicated as to the
availability of that existing capacity
and you're gonna hear about that now
there's production capacity that gets
better and better and better and that's
what we're talking about because for
what we need now we believe that with
better communications we'll be able to
make that happen
so I know there's gonna be a lot of
questions about that I didn't want to go
on too long but let me just finish by
saying given what I just said and what I
believe what you're going to hear that
for what we need in the first phase if
these things are done correctly what I
believe they can we will have and there
will be enough tests to allow us to take
this country safely through phase one
Thank You mr. vice president I want to
make a few comments here first I want to
talk a little bit about CDC has
developed multiple systems to monitor
disease outbreaks I think many of you
are familiar for example how we monitor
for foodborne illness or how we monitor
for antibiotic resistance in hospitals
well we've also developed a system to
monitor for upper respiratory tract
disease I can get the first slide there
this is an example because when we talk
about what we know about this current
pandemic the reality is we know a lot
because we've developed these monitoring
systems up on the slide is a system that
we've developed initially for flu and
what it does as you can see there's a
multiple different flu seasons and they
track them over the course of a year I
want you to look at the red line and
that happens to be this year's
respiratory season and you see there's a
peak there up over the 50 52-week and
that peak was when we actually had a
peak of influenza B this year was a
little different because after that
viral syndrome came down and you can see
it that actually we had another peak and
that's when influenza A was active
through our country and you can see
influenza A started to drop but then you
saw a third peak that peak was you were
looking at the corona virus 19 so we
have systems all the way down to the
county level that we can see where
there's respiratory tract illness and so
it's not just just taking a test it's
monitoring these systems that have been
developed over the last over decades and
we have multiple ones we have another
one this that is monitored in emergency
rooms looking at syndrome diagnosis and
they show the same thing so we're well
equipped to monitor to see when
respiratory tract viral disease will
come
and becomes a very good surrogate for
when you can begin to understand that we
need to start looking more ideologically
about what's going on you can see now in
week 15 we're really coming down to the
baseline background in terms of our flu
surveillance system from the overall
coronavirus situation right now the
second thing I wanted to say is that CDC
continues to enhance the state's public
health capacity to accelerate their
ability as Tony talked about it's
critical as we open America again to
diagnose individuals that present with
influenza like illness or coronavirus
like illness to diagnose them to be able
to isolate them and to be able to
contact trace around them and then
diagnose the contacts and those that are
coronavirus positive to go back and do
their contacts this is the traditional
public health approach which was started
in this outbreak in in January in
February and was quite successful when
as I mentioned before through February
27th this country only had 14 cases we
did that isolation and that contact
tracing and it was very successful but
then when the virus more exploded got
beyond the public health capacity but
right now CDC is enhancing that public
health capacity and if I can get the
second slide I want to show you that
this is just showing as we sit here
today that CDC has embedded in these
health departments and all of these
state states across this country more
than 500 individuals we also have an
additional almost hundred individuals
that are working on more than 20
coronavirus outbreaks that are going
through all these states and and finally
at the direction of the president we've
been asked to further enhance this
deployment in each of the states as the
vice president said so that there's
additional public health personnel to
help accelerate the state's ability to
basically move forward aggressively
and we assist them so they can
operationalize the president's
guidelines to open up America again so I
just wanted to make those points for
either today thank you dr. Burks Thank
You mr. vice president and thank you dr.
Falchi and dr. Redfield for all of that
clarity if we can have the next slide
I'm gonna go back to what dr. Falchi was
talking about just to emphasize those
points about the two types of tests and
I'm gonna talk about a third one so
first we all know about sampling in the
front of your nose to all of the labs
out there and to the providers you don't
have to use the nasal pharyngeal swab
anymore you can do front of nose
sampling and again as dr. Falchi talked
about is that as sampling for the virus
itself that replicates in your nose and
as we know throughout some of the
respiratory tissues the second test is a
course then your immune response to that
infection that's in your nose and so
that's the antibody test and so those
are the two tests we want to talk about
but I want to come back to something
that both dr. Fauci and dr. Redfield
said and we covered yesterday testing is
a part of the exquisite monitoring that
needs to occur in partnership with CDC
and state and local governments
utilizing the surveillance systems that
are available what we just talked about
the flu surveillance system because we
no longer have flu and the syndromic
respiratory system that is across the
United States and you can see it's going
back to baseline so that we'll be able
to see at the community level any
deviation from that baseline in addition
what we talked about yesterday was
adding that asymptomatic component
because I think you'll see as more and
more articles come out for surveillance
that other and monitoring that other
states have done higher and higher
antibody in multiple individuals who
don't remember having a sickness and
that will give us an idea that's our
asymptomatic monitoring in these
Sentinel monitoring sites and what did
we talk about yesterday we talked about
nursing homes we talked about indigenous
people and we talked about vulnerable
people in the inner city really ensuring
that something that is so small that
can't even be seen on the surveillance
monitoring will be able to be seen in
the asymptomatic and so those are the
two tests that we have one available now
two that have been approved or three by
the FDA I want to just leave you with my
last concept on the antibody tests
antibody tests have different
specificity and sensitivities the FDA
we've made that there FDA's been very
cautious about the antibody test because
I heat see I know you see reports every
day of countries that have ordered the
antibody test and found that they were
50 60 70 percent faulty so we're taking
that very seriously because you never
want to tell someone that they have an
antibody and potential immunity when
they don't and so those tests perform
better when there's a high prevalence or
high incidence of disease so we want to
work with mayor's around the United
States as those antibody tests become
available to really see what it is in
first responders and healthcare workers
in the highest prevalence States so that
we can know about the quality and the
real-life real field experience of those
assays because things can look very good
in the lab and then when you take them
into the field sometimes they're not as
good I've learned this lesson repeatedly
in working around the globe the next
slide so this is what we have asked
commercial and diagnostic companies to
be working on because when you talk
about multi millions worth of tests the
way we do this in the United States
today for strep flu in further influenza
and for malaria is we test for the
antigen now we don't know right now is
bution air antigen in the front of your
nose and so that is the question that's
scientists and and companies are working
on right now because that becomes a
simpler test now the flu test I think
many of you will look it up tonight you
will see that outside of the flu season
because of the specificity of the test
it doesn't work so well so these are
tests we're working on today that would
be like a screening test because if
you're positive on it it's a good test
but it may miss that you actually have
the flu so then you would move into that
what we call the nucleic acid test so
we're trying to build an algorithm of
tests that bring the full talent of the
science of the United States into the
reality of the clinic and so bench de
clinic and so this is what we're working
on for the future next slide so as I
promised on both the senators and the
governors this is the United States
current platform capacity designated as
high and low throughput and what do I
mean by that there's we've talked about
the high throughput platforms abroach
and Abbott and others and then we've
talked about the gene expert and other
machines that may be moderate to lower
throughput I want you to see how it's
distributed through the United States so
these are the current testing platforms
available today
throughout the United States for kovat
19 and as you heard from dr. Falchi
everything has to be working from the
swab to the transport media to the
laboratory to really get those tests run
and the results back to the client the
next slide so then we've looked into all
of the testing capacity from those
platforms and this gives you an idea of
what that capacity is the darkest red
you can see like in Texas and New York
those are in - those are states that
have lots of different platforms as you
saw on the prior slide and the ability
if you just add up the platforms and the
potential for tests of over a million
tests per month and so this is what
we're working with each of those states
on unlocking that full
potential and how are we doing that well
we're caught we're calling on the
American Society of microbiologists
they have they work closely with 300 lab
directors around this around the country
we talked with them this morning and the
Walter Reed team who developed the
entire HIV testing program for the
military 35 years ago I've called them
back into service and they're are
calling lab by lab to find out what are
the technical difficulties to bring up
all the platforms that exist in your
labs is it swathes is it transport media
is it extraction and I just really want
to thank them they've already worked
through over 70 plus of those
laboratories to really understand and
the American Society of microbiologists
and the academic societies of the
laboratories are working together to
ensure that all of this potential can be
unlocked next slide please
we talked a little bit yesterday about
New Orleans and we and the president
talked about how many tests New Orleans
has done I'm during its outbreak which
you can see now is waning they've done
throughout the last month 27 tests per
thousand New Orleans and Louisiana uns
so 27 per thousand so that is a good
mark and that's what Italy has done
about 20 per thousand so in evaluating
an outbreak and really to get control of
this outbreak they did about 27 tests
per thousand so using that as a measure
next slide we then looked at cross all
the states of the United States of
America and looked for states that had
30 or more ability to do 30 or more
tests per thousand of their inhabitants
in each state and you can see that
across the country except for or a gun
and Maine and
I worked overseas way too long
thank you all so those are the three
states that were working on building
capacity again so this is just to give
you a perspective of how seriously we're
taking the testing issue as we've
described we measured every single
platform in every single state we know
exactly where they are by geography by
address by zip code what their capacity
is what their cumulative capacity is
what their roadblocks are on not ability
to run all their full capacity and we're
addressing those because each one of
those is different and you have to
address each of them one by one with the
governor's with the state and local labs
and with all of the hospitals I have not
come across one laboratory or one
laboratory director or one society that
doesn't want to contribute to solving
this issue of testing and ensuring that
this testing is available for everyone
there is a strong just as all the
Americans have social distance in behind
everyone we don't often talk about the
laboratories will talk about the nurses
and doctors on the front line behind all
of them are the laboratory technicians
and laboratory directors who are coming
in every day and putting things together
to ensure that every single person that
needs to be diagnosed is diagnosed and
hopefully you can see from these labs I
mean these slides that really there is
capacity out there it is our job working
with the states and having the state in
the leadership role in the laboratory
directors in the leadership role to
provide support to ensure that all the
potential for testing in the United
States is brought to bear I just want to
end with these are nucleic acid tests
there will never be the ability on a
nucleic acid test to do 300 million
tests a day or to test everybody before
they go to work or to school but there
might be with the antigen test and so
that's why there's a role for nucleic
acid test there's a role for antibody
test and there's a role for the future
development of these other key tests to
bring the full ability to the United
States and so when we finish this will
be
talking to all Americans because there's
other tests that other Americans should
have and I think this is really brought
to light the importance of diagnosis and
we'll talk to you further about
hepatitis C and TB and other things that
we can do to sure every American is
healthy because I think this is really
raised the awareness among all Americans
about how you do tests for different
kinds in different parts of your disease
State and what is long-lasting immunity
and what may be long-lasting immunity
and what is a nucleic acid test and what
an antigen test is and with that I will
Gerard and let me amplify one point as
the Admiral steps forward to included
remarks about our approach and the
efforts we've put under way governor's
across the country have been working
very closely with us to roll out the
level of testing that we have today and
all the information we presented to you
is going to be reviewed in the days
ahead with all of our governor's our
objective is to connect every one of
America's governors and state health
officials and to all of the labs that
are currently able to do a corona virus
and but as as as dr. Burke's doctor
pouchy both described we believe today
that we have the capacity in the United
States to do a sufficient amount of
testing for States to move into phase
one at the time and manner that they
deemed to be appropriate with that I'll
allow Admiral Terada complete our
briefing on testing and we expect the
President to return Thank You mr. vice
president and thank you to all my really
great colleagues can I have so I I
wanted to start by where we are today
just to visit where we've come in such a
short period of time as everyone on the
stage has said before our testing right
now is well over three point seven eight
million tests that have been completed
and if you are impressed by bar graphs
that's over 1.2 million tests reported
just in the way
week ambassador birx talked to me a
little earlier and she said you know we
only do about two million molecular
tests a year for HIV something that's
been done for developed for 35 years
we're now doing twice that number of
tests in a month for a disease that has
never been known before that there's
never been a test developed before and
that's sort of where we are and where we
ramped up I also want to give you a
little idea the lighter blue or lighter
gray is is our our ID now tests so we
talked about them a lot because they are
a point-of-care test that can be between
five and fifteen minutes and they have a
very specific role but they're not for
everybody if you've got a screen a few
thousand people for test an hour doesn't
get you there on a machine you have to
use some of the larger higher throughput
items but they have a very important
role and again coming into the market at
50,000 per day is really an important
adjunct to us um she talked about the
gene expert from Sofia very important we
don't talk about that very much but it
is one of the backbone mobile point of
care not as easy to do per se as the
Abbott but it is a point of care test
that really carries tuberculosis
screening all through Africa there are
these machines you saw that on her slide
every one of the 50 states has this in
over 600 sites and they've done over 700
thousand tests just on that relatively
low throughput but very important
platform next slide please
I wanted to give you an idea sort of how
the tests are distributed and how
they're changing over time on the left
are the state public health laboratories
and although their numbers are
relatively small about 350,000 the state
public health laboratories are
absolutely critical they're they're an
absolutely critical core component of
our testing not only were they there
early in first but they also do things
like support outbreak investigations and
nursing homes or investigations in
certain plants that
have a close proximity with everyone
because of their work environments they
also do testing on many people who do
not have the opportunity to be tested
elsewhere and they are performing
outstandingly well a CLA I know we hate
acronyms but the American Clinical
Laboratory Association this is America's
commercial industrial backbone that were
standing behind the president the
vice-president and and when I was there
a few weeks ago in the Rose Garden this
is the lab core the quest the bio
reference laboratory Mayo sonic in a RUP
and you'll see they've done almost 2.3
million tests this is the very large
high-throughput machines that dr. Burks
talks about and and I want to be clear
about about this group is that it
doesn't matter where you are I just took
one of the largest labs and I said map
out for me where you are with with it
within 10 miles of where you are every
site in the country and when you do that
within 10 miles of a site of one of
these 93 percent of the US population is
covered these are truly national
reference labs that cover almost
everybody within the United States so if
you cannot get a test at your hospital
the chances are overwhelming that you
could send this to these labs that are
fully caught up now they have no backlog
of tests they've ramped up their
production so their turnaround time is
about 48 hours because you may need to
transport it from the middle of America
out to a lab and result that but that's
really very very very good the American
Hospital Association also academic labs
as the vice president and the president
have said as more and more labs come
online they are increasing the amount of
testing that are done just at the
hospitals or at academic academic
medical centers now almost at 600,000
tests and again matching the other slide
I had the avid point-of-care test just
to give you a distribution and that
point-of-care test is being used very
importantly in very selective
populations where a point-of-care test
is really
that could be in some hospitals where
someone needs to know exactly if a
person is positive or not to go on a
clinical trial or in a nursing home
investigation or sometimes to get people
screen to go back into the work
environment most people don't need a
point-of-care test in fact a
point-of-care test does not cannot
replace the millions of tests that are
here on the other side next slide
I don't know how interested you are in
swabs I did not know a whole lot of
swabs before a few weeks ago but there's
two points I want to make with with
these slides is yes there have been
constraining elements and they're
constrained for a couple reasons number
one because this is an unprecedented
scale up of this type of very
sophisticated molecular test that has
never put a demand on a system like we
have when we started out a few weeks ago
there's very specific one type of swab
only get at one place in the u.s. one
place in Italy and we were stuck with
that for a while because it's not just
the quantity it's the quality what I
don't want to do is put a lot of things
in the system to make people believe
that this is a good test when it hasn't
been validated by the FDA to say that a
positive is a positive and a negative is
a negative
but over the past weeks both the
scientific community the Gates
Foundation academic medical centers the
FDA have really opened up our ability to
not stick that all the way back in your
nasopharynx but do the anterior nose and
to greatly broaden the amount of swab
types that are available so we are
really at a point right now that over
the neck by the end of April we'll put
another five million swabs in addition
to everything that's out there now and
by the end of May over 12 million new
swabs in the system more than enough to
obtain the capacity that we need yes for
these molecular tests you take a swab
and you stick it in a test tube and that
task tube has to have a specific kind of
liquid in it and when we started it was
a viral transport media very special
kind of media the CDC has to make your
own recipe if you're interested in
cooking you could probably do that but
it has a lot of ingredients that go in
there but still
very limiting we've worked with many
many different laboratories we've worked
with the FDA so now PBS phosphate
buffered saline a kind of just
laboratory grade salt water can be used
for this this greatly opens the ability
to expand the test to support all the
capability that dr. Burks talks about
and again by the end of April we will
have put well over five million new
tubes of either viral transport media or
saline into the system I am going to get
to a conclusion here but this was going
to be more of a technical briefing next
slide so let's talk about the fact that
the science tells us that we have and
will continue to have enough tests to
safely go into Phase one so let me be
very granular about this we've already
heard that it is beyond the possibility
to test everyone in this country every
day it's just it's not possible but it's
also a bad strategy because testing a
person now just means they're negative
now doctor foul she could be positive
tomorrow because it's brewing in his
system right now and we don't know it or
that he contacts that that's not the way
we go about things the way we go about
things as dr. Redfield said just just
think of the weather radar okay if the
weather radar is clear you're not going
to have a thunderstorm or tornado when
something pops up that's when you've got
to go to where the action is or know
that your warning system is up so sort
of think of that in the background and
I'll go specifically about that
so that's monitoring let me talk about
how much testing we need just for
overall testing I'm just gonna give you
a number I'm not saying that this is the
number that's there but lets us take a
number that we are going to enter phase
one when there are two hundred thousand
new cases per month in the United States
don't get hung up on that it's going to
be much less than that but let's just
say two hundred thousand cases so how
many tests do we need well we need to
test those two hundred thousand people
to make the diagnosis right
everybody nod your head about that we
have to do that now what's a safe number
over that you know if everybody I test
has the disease I'm not testing enough
right but if I test a hundred people to
have one person with the disease that's
probably over testing so we kind of
assumed that a safe number that really
gives us a good idea is if about one out
of ten people are positive then we know
we're over sampling the population
enough that we're getting all the
positives so if there's 200,000 cases I
need about two million tests okay now to
go to dr. red Phil's point each one of
those that are positive have contacts
that need to be traced in on average the
CDC tells me that for every positive
there are about five contacts that
really need to be traced so let's assume
that those 200,000 people have five
contacts so now we have an extra million
test so two million tests out there to
detect the 200,000 cases an extra
million out there to trace those
contacts so we're up to about three
million cases if you want to put a fudge
factor say that's four million tests
okay those are generally done at the
main hospital labs the commercial labs
state and regional labs all this can be
done as well as some of the labs talked
about by dr. Burks next slide the second
group of testing fits exactly perfectly
with the influenza like surveillance
system that dr. Redfield talked about
this is the monitoring this is sort of
the radar but the weather radar that it
would be out there that we're not
testing people who are symptomatic we
want to do testing on people who are
asymptomatic because you can have
asymptomatic carriage Yod you know you
could you could have this virus and shed
it and not have symptoms or only mild
symptoms so what is the strategy here
the strategy here this is an
unprecedented strategy okay this is this
is really unprecedented but we're going
to do prop between three and five
hundred thousand tests per week in the
most vulnerable populations that we know
that the virus could circulate and what
are they
number one nursing home and long-term
care facilities we know that from the
history of this of this virus that that
can circulate and be devastating and it
could circulate even in a way that you
don't have symptoms so we're gonna
survey in a very controlled way driven
by the CDC supervised by the CDC surveys
over we may not get to everyone but
surveying in the areas to cover in a
selective way the fifteen thousand or so
nursing homes secondly we want to work
in vulnerable members in cities and this
is the way we think about that is
community health centers I'm a huge fan
of community health centers that are led
by hersa there are there are about
thirty thousand community health center
sites they take care of 30 million
people children adults elderly they care
for about one-third of Americans below
the poverty level
they are arrayed to take care of our
most vulnerable populations so we want
to survey on asymptomatic people in
those community health centers we also
want to do and some of our indigenous
population and you know very early I was
out here bringing machines to the Indian
Health Service and in fact 1800 members
of the Public Health Service provide
care to the Indian Health Service and
their director and chief medical officer
are both Admirals in the Indian Health
Service Plus work fete workplace
monitoring particularly for workplace
environments that may have very close
contact or may have a high risk and some
of those could be agricultural
facilities so let's just total that out
we have 200,000 people who need a
diagnosis to make that diagnosis we want
to test 2 million okay so that's 2
million we're going to contact trace
with a million and let us throw you a
fudge factor of about 25 percent on that
so that's 4 million and we have this
background testing of about 400 of about
400,000 per month so to safely do the
testing we need to be in the range of
four and a half million you followed my
number so I want you to understand
per month that pardon me for phase 1
right for phase 1 and I want to tell you
that's really how it adds up and that's
where we are right now we're doing about
1 1 million to 1.2 million per week we
are going to continue to push that
farther and further as we open up the
laboratories and were able to open all
the supplies that we need for that and I
think that's where I would like to end
thank you thank you I'll ask the team to
step back up for questions and we do
anticipate see schedule permitted that
the president be returning momentarily
yeah that's a great question and it what
we will be doing is monitoring how much
we have to use in phase one to really
help inform phase two because it what
the really unknown in this to be
completely transparent is asymptomatic
and asymptomatic spread and so if we
find that there's a lot of asymptomatic
individuals that we find in this active
monitoring in what we can see are very
much concerned about the most vulnerable
then we will have to have increased
testing to cover all of those all of
those sites and as we've made clear to
the governor's and other health
officials we're going to continue to
scale testing as the president's made
clear we want we want governors and
states to manage the testing operations
in their states we've given we've given
criteria we've given guidance for how we
think that would best operate but we're
looking for the states we're looking for
the governor's to manage it but in the
midst of that all these great experts
working with all these great facilities
are going to continue to use that great
American ingenuity to scale and increase
the availability of testing for states
to be able to implement as they move
closer and closer to that that day the
president speaks of often where we
reopen America and put all
America back to work earlier today jay
Inslee said that your tweets encouraging
separation I said your tweets
encouraging liberation in Michigan
Minnesota of Virginia where foam in st.
rebellion wondering how that squares
with the the sober and methodical
guidance that you issued yesterday well
I think we do have a so green guidance
but I think some things are too tough
and if you look at some of the states
you just mentioned it it's too tough not
only relative to this but what they've
done in Virginia with respect to the
second amendment is just a horrible
thing they did a horrible thing the
governor and he's the governor under a
cloud to start off with so when you see
what he said about the second amendment
when you see what other states have done
no I think I feel very comfortable go
ahead just to be clear when you talk
about these states on Michigan Minnesota
Virginia do you think that they should
live there stay in home borders or can
you talk but open I think elements of
what they've done is too much it's just
too much you know the elements because
I've already said but certainly a second
amendment and second amendment having to
do with the state of Virginia what
they've done in Virginia is just
incredible
okay please sir are you concerned though
that people coming out in protest are
going to spread Cova to other people
they're congregating in ways that health
experts have said they should not know
these are people expressing their views
I see where they are and I see the way
they're working they seem to be very
responsible people to me but it's you
know they've been treated a little bit
rough
next we might see as the country begins
reopening as you feel kind of like a
puzzle so as you've mentioned we have
States but we're already seeing their
curves begin to flatten but then there
are others like Florida or more rural
parts of the country where they aren't
projected to peak for weeks or even
months so can you talk a little bit
about some of the difficulties that
those later peaking States might face if
they need to stay locked down for longer
even as other places around them are
starting to open up well we're seeing
great numbers in almost every state
we're seeing big drops we're really
seeing in terms of beds the numbers we
have to look at are the beds the beds
being occupied people going which is
essentially people going in that means
that you have fewer people that are sick
fewer people that feel they have to go
to a hospital and those numbers are
dropping really precipitously so I think
that we're just seeing a lot of good
signs now a place like New York New
Jersey and certain parts of Louisiana
Louisiana has been incredible lately
would you look at that drop that drop
has really been great
Michigan's had a hard time but it's it's
starting to do well so I just think
Illinois is another one you know you
look at some of the numbers but everyone
is is dropping and they're dropping
rather quickly we don't have any hotspot
that's developed where all of a sudden
you say well other than we did have a
meatpacking plant or two we're
incredibly we had some you saw the
number was rather incredible it took
place in that plant people could ask
about that I wonder who owned that
company there's a weird situation but
generally speaking it's been very good
the numbers have been really improving
greatly please in the bench mr.
president US intelligence is saying this
week that the coronavirus likely came
from a level 4 lab and whoo-hah
there's also another report that the NIH
under the Obama administration in 2015
gave that lab 3.7 million dollars in a
grant why would the US with a grant like
that to China the Obama administration
gave them a grant of 3.7 million I've
been hearing about that and we've
instructed that if any grants are going
to that area were looking at it
literally about an hour ago and also
early in the morning we will end that
grant very quickly but it was granted
quite a while ago they were granted a
substantial amount of money we're gonna
look at it and take a look but I
understand it was a number of years ago
did you hear what did you hear was the
grant was 2015 2015
mr. president we know negotiations are
underway for the next round of funding
for small business though
if tens of billions of dollars went in a
matter of days the first time well this
next what we've package be enough well I
think it will certainly it's gonna get
us to a point that's going to be rather
beautiful we think that that will be the
point and it could be they want more but
maybe at a certain point we're going to
stop it's been a tremendous success it's
been executed flawlessly SBA's done a
very good job but the banks have done a
great job whether it's Bank of America
Wells Fargo the the community banks have
been incredible I think we had over
4,000 community banks a lot of people
didn't know you had that many banks but
4,000 community banks they gave the
money out it's so organized and it's
been such a great program and so
essentially we're waiting for 250
billion dollars the Democrats are
refusing to do it this is money that
essentially is going to the workers it's
going to keep these companies whole the
restaurants and a lot of great companies
and it's a small amount of money
relative to what it represents because
it represents small businesses it
represents them staying in business and
you know when you look at it people
don't know small businesses represent
approximately 50% of the power of our
business enterprises
big monster businesses that you read
about every day it's all of these small
businesses when added it's something
that should be approved by the Democrats
the Republicans wanted badly and the
people wanted very badly
Oh nearly 10% of the loans that were
given out were for 5 million dollars but
some small business owners say they
can't even get a loan for $100,000 is
that what they would know they would get
that but they have to approve an Adu
nobody knew it was gonna be this
successful don't forget when you say the
money's gone it's been a tremendous
success as a program people are they
really want it and some people won't be
able to get there keep their business
open unless they get that money it's
been a tremendous success it's been
executed flawlessly it's been I mean
with few exceptions it's really been
good and I think the Democrats are gonna
do it look Nancy Pelosi she's away on a
vacation or something and she should
come back she should come back and get
this done
I don't know why she's not coming back
the fact is she's not doing her job and
there's nothing unusual about that well
hospitals are a good thing hospitals
have been decimated by this you know
they've given up their business which is
good because they did the right thing in
order to take care of the köppen 19 and
no hospitals I'm with that all the way
they want to add to hospitals we could
also add it into phase 4 if we do a
phase floor phase 4 would be hopefully
infrastructure a lot of people are
talking about the best thing we could do
for this country would be the payroll
tax cut that I've been suggested
suggesting a lot of Democrats like it
believe it or not the payroll tax cut
and art Laffer whose tremendous he's a
tremendous in fact he recently got the
Presidential Medal of Freedom economist
it was with Ronald Reagan he's been he
looks like he's 25 years old but I think
you might be a little bit older than
that he looks so great but art Laffer
said the single best thing you can do is
the payroll tax cut and I would just
about agree with that and I'd like to
see that I'm not sure that we're gonna
get that but I think that's something
that could be done it's simple it's
really good for both the company that
employ
these people and for the people that are
employed so we're gonna see whether that
happens or not the payroll I put it out
there the payroll tax cut would be a
tremendous incentive for this country
Stephen China now says it's Kelowna
buyers death poll in Wuhan is 50% higher
up to about four thousand does that
sound like a credible number to you well
you know when I listen to the press
every night saying we have the most we
don't have the most in the world deaths
the most in the world has to be China
it's a massive country it's gone through
a tremendous problem with us a
tremendous problem and they must have
the most so today I saw they announced
that essentially they're doubling up on
the numbers and that's only in Wuhan
they're not talking about outside of
Wuhan so it is what it is safe it is
what it is what I said what a sad state
of affairs investigation and the whether
the virus escaped from this lab and move
on how is that we're looking at a lot of
people are looking at it it seems to
make sense they talk about a certain
kind of bat but that bat wasn't in that
area if you can believe this that's what
they're down to now is bats but that bat
is not in that area that bat wasn't sold
at that wet zone it wasn't salt there
that bat is 40 miles away so a lot of
strange things are happening but there
is a lot of investigation going on and
we're gonna find out all I can say is
wherever it came from came from China in
whatever form 184 countries now are
suffering because of it and it's too bad
isn't it and it could have been solved
or easily when it was just starting it
could have been solved really very
easily thank you sir so about the 80
million payments that have gone out
imagine who said that less than one
person
have had snack foods but that could be
800,000 snack foods so we've also seen
what I'm saying it's less than 1% and
the snafu is a very minor they were they
were eighteen eighty million payments
went out over a period of a few days and
they caught certain mistakes that they
made but this is a tiny amount of
mistakes I can tell you a mistakes were
made in government we're wrong countries
were signed okay eighty million this has
been a tremendous success and any
mistake that was made they've been
caught and it's less than one percent
that's a very good percentage I can tell
you for government I mean how about how
about the Obama website the Obama care
website where they spend five billion
dollars on building a website that you
could have built for for peanuts
[Music]
anything that was sent that sometimes
you send a check to somebody wrong
sometimes people are listed they die and
they get a check that can happen you're
talking about I guess the number is
about 80 million people yeah sure we'll
get that back everything we're gonna get
back but it's a tiny amount they've done
a fantastic job this was done in a
matter of a few days yes um your
campaign said today that they are
planning on resuming rallies before the
election is there a timeline that you're
looking at would it be restricted to
certain states how that would work well
I hope we can do rallies it's great for
the country it's great spirit it's great
for a lot of things it's a that to me
it's a tremendous way of getting the
word out if you look at our success rate
we've had tremendous success we win
where we have rallies including
endorsements of candidates our success
rate is I think unparalleled there's
nothing like it so I certainly hope we
can have rallies we'll find out I don't
like the rally is where we're sitting
like you're sitting I mean you got many
reporters outside trying to get into
this room and I come in I'm looking at
this room and I see all this it loses a
lot of flavor it loses to me a lot of
flavor but I hope we're gonna have
rallies I think they're gonna be bigger
than ever I will say this the rallies
that we're having
until we had to stop with regard to the
problem that we had here the rallies
were bigger than they were I think even
substantially bigger we go into the
biggest arena would turn away twenty
thirty thousand people sometimes in in
one case I think they said in New Jersey
we had a hundred and seventy five
thousand people show up for an arena
there holds nine thousand people and
they showed up and the reporters even
reported that that was almost shocking
to me but I hope we can resume rallies
because I think they're an important
part of politics actually some workers
can go back to work in phase one but
schools cannot reopen until phase two
many parents don't have an option
to work from home so how can you get
businesses back up and running as long
as schools are closed well I think the
businesses are going to and I think now
we've given the businesses a real jolt a
real positive jolt they were able to
keep their employees you know without
the employees if the employees leave
that area if they leave you know who
knows where they're going or if they get
another job maybe someplace else you're
not gonna have the same business so we
gave them money to hold their employees
they're going to do that we hope we can
do two hundred and fifty billion dollars
more it's it's absolutely so inexpensive
compared to what it represents and we
hope that's going to happen but I think
I really think look you see it with a
stock market the market was up seven or
eight hundred points today and if you
would have told me that we would have a
virus the likes of which this world has
not seen since 1917 which was the
Spanish flu where anywhere from 75 to
100 million people were killed and that
we'd have a stock market that's not far
below its all-time high and it's
starting to get a little low you know
then you had a thousand point increase
and a 1200 point increase so now we have
a stock market that's at a point where
it's not very far away from where it was
and we've gone through it closed
literally a closed country remember this
also I mean we have had a closed economy
we had the best economy anywhere in the
world by far we're the best economy we
ahead remember this the dollar is very
strong and dollars strong dollars are
overall very good but it does cause
problem it's harder to sell outside of
the country etc it's a little harder for
manufacturers sometimes it's a lot
harder everybody wants to invest in our
country everybody wants and you know
we're paying almost zero in interest
like in some cases zero we've never had
that before people want the safety of
our country but if you would have told
me that a market was where it is today
and today we had almost I guess more
than a 700 point increase and we're at a
point which is you know that's not what
it was but it's not that far off I would
have told you that's got to be in a plus
but the reason that is is because there
is a great pent-up demand this country
is gonna come back and it's gonna come
back strong we have to get rid of the
virus we've got to open up our country
we're gonna open it up in quadrants
we're gonna open it up as States some of
the states should get together and they
should work on their own borders and
everything because you don't want to
have people pouring through a border of
a state that isn't infected and you have
people coming but perhaps outside that's
one of the reasons I was asking Tony two
days ago about masks well why in Wyoming
or Montana would they have to wear masks
that numbers are very good the reason if
if somebody comes from outside you know
which is a very severe but it's again
and it's gonna be up to them it's a
recommendation but we'll see but if you
would have told me how well we're doing
after we went through the worst event of
its kind since 1917 it's pretty amazing
those Americans aren't sure how they can
go back to work if schools are closed
where how can they have their picnic
something in addition to helping
employees stay employees we have a good
question I think the schools are gonna
be open soon I think a lot of Governors
are already talking about schools being
opened and we do have to take care of
our seniors because we've learned a lot
about this disease we've learned call it
a disease we've learned a lot about this
plague and we have to take care of our
seniors we're going to take care of a
lot of people but
I think the schools are going to be open
sooner rather than later and I
understand and I've spoken some
governor's are already talking about
thinking about getting the schools open
I have a young boy who goes to school
I'd like to see him go to school as good
as home is it's very nice but we'd like
to see him go to school please
Thank You mr. president I agree at that
point I would like to know about some of
these areas that you'd like to open up
some of these quadrants you singled out
Virginia Michigan they don't have a
decline in cases yet you tweeted out
today that you'd like to liberate them
well they're gonna have soon but they're
very very very what they've done is very
powerful in terms of I think you know
you could get the same result out of
doing a little bit less what they've
done to some people is very unfair in
Virginia I'm going above and beyond what
we're talking about with this horrible
plague they want to take their guns away
okay they want to take their guns away
that's the Second Amendment
that's Virginia you have a government
governor who really I guess he should be
under seas she seems not to be if he
were a Republican he'd be under siege
but he seems to have escaped something
that was pretty bad
including what he said about birth
including what he said about many
different things but he wants to take if
you take a look at what's going on in
Virginia they want to take away Second
Amendment rights and that's what they
want to do so when you talk about
liberate or if you talk about a
liberation you could certainly look at
Virginia as one go ahead anybody else
see which states are ready to reopen in
your mind and how some well I don't want
to go I want to leave the governor's
make that decision we're watching very
closely if we see something happening
bad that we think is wrong we're going
to come down very strong in that very
very strong the federal government is a
lot to say we have we have a lot to say
beyond what anyone understands and we
think and and I've gotten to know many
of the governor's many Democrats too
it's Republicans and I knew the
Republicans I knew some of the Democrats
but I got to know a lot of them I think
it's going to be in the hands of a lot
of good people I think a lot of good
people are looking at this and they want
to do what's right Steve
nice present is travelling serve and I
think tomorrow Colorado why are you
gonna be in a position to travel again
well they'd rather not have me travel I
think I've been in the White House I
don't know four months
I don't know how what it is but it's
four months other than I did leave to to
say goodbye to our beautiful ship right
the comfort the as it left Virginia with
got out of drydock it got out of
maintenance very early it was supposed
to be there for four weeks it was there
for a few days literally we got it up to
New York I mean they didn't they didn't
need it like well I wouldn't say we
hoped I'm glad that in needed they
didn't need it that was a good thing
they didn't need the Convention Center
2500 beds or depending on your
definition 2900 we ultimately converted
it to kovat the Army Corps of Engineers
and FEMA the job they did was incredible
but that's a sign that they're making
progress in New York if you look at that
you know we built it it was ready it's
there now it's ready we converted it to
Cova it wasn't supposed to be for that
the request of frankly our side then
ultimately we converted it but there is
much less demand that's such a good
thing I mean I'm not complaining about
that I think it's a great at that means
New York's making progress he's going to
corrupt Colorado I think he's going to
the Air Force to make the commencement
yes oh I think it's great I think it's
great if he's going to make the commands
which I hear they're going to have a
very spread out Fred yes sir
they're going to be safe they are going
to be socially very good they're gonna
be very far apart that'll be very
interesting I think I'm gonna watch that
one no they're going to be they're gonna
have a good spread a good distance apart
I spoke to Mike about it no I think
making the comment commencement speech
I'm doing it at West Point which I look
forward to I did it last year Air Force
I did it at Annapolis I did it at the
Coast Guard Academy and I'm doing it at
West Point and I assume they're they've
got it and I understand they'll have
distancing they'll have some big
distances so it'll be very different
than it ever looked do I like the look
no I do
and eventually next year they'll have a
commencement which will be like it's
been like when people like this are
great Admiral has done such a great job
when he graduated from where he
graduated me to we're nice and tight and
that's gonna happen again I don't want
people to think that this is gonna be
like this forever but for a period of
time we're gonna have to keep it that
way that includes baseball games and
football games and other things but
eventually as this virus goes away it's
gonna be better and better direct here
it's gonna be better and better and
we're gonna get our lives back to the
way they were you know one thing that
bothers me a couple of Restaurant tours
called and they said that I mean sir I
barely made a living with a hundred and
fifty seats now if I do what they want
me to do I'll be down to 25 seats and I
can't I said yeah but you're not gonna
be there forever and he didn't really
know that he thought that they were
gonna take a hundred and fifty seats
move it down to 25 to 50 seats depending
on the way he laid it out he said don't
worry about it eventually you're gonna
be back to the scene that you used to
have which was look I could tell you
about and I'm not gonna do it because I
didn't want to bring it up but I could
tell you about events that took place
and I said things like you'll never do
that again or you'll never do this again
or I don't even want to mention the
events I don't want to mention what
you're supposed to be doing because and
you know one of them was so horrible I
said a certain industry will be out of
business never happen again two weeks
later was like nothing ever happened
hopefully we get rid of this we have
tremendous talent up here and all over
including governor's including local
governments state governments I look
forward to the time to me when we can
really normalize but normalizing is
being back to where we were yeah please
go ahead mr. president some of your
allies are calling for China to be
stripped as host of the 2022 2022
it's wondering what you make of that is
that's something that you would consider
or so I just made a deal with China
where they're going to put in two
hundred and fifty billion dollars of
product they're gonna be they're gonna
be buying two hundred and fifty fifty
from forty to fifty billion in form I
want to see what's happening with China
I want to see how they're doing on it
are they fulfilling the deal the
transaction we have a lot of discussions
going on with China let me just put it
this way I'm not happy okay
I'm not happy and I spoke to them and
this could have been shut down a long
time ago they knew it and we couldn't
get in and the whole fairness world
health couldn't get in and that's why I
wish they took a different stance they
would took a very pathetic stance and a
very weak stance but they say they
couldn't get in but ultimately they got
in they got in much sooner than anybody
but they didn't report what was
happening they didn't report what was
happening inside of China no I'm not
happy with China dr. Kashi could you
address these suggestions or concerns
that this virus was somehow man-made
[Music]
there was a study recently that we can
make available to you where a group of
highly qualified evolutionary biologists
looked at the sequences there and the
sequences in bats as they evolved and
the mutations that it took to get to the
point where it is now is totally
consistent with a jump of a species from
an animal to a human so I mean the paper
will be available I don't have them for
others right now but we can make that
available to officer on the process
you that we've seen the economies to
open does that concern you though as a
health expert when you see folks
congregate and are you worried you pass
encouraged well I mean I'm looking at it
from a public health standpoint I
certainly could understand the
frustration of people but my main role
in the task force is to make
recommendations to protect the health
and the safety of the American people
and I would hope that people understand
that that's the reason why we're doing
what we're doing and hopefully we'll put
an end to this very very satisfied with
the decision we made listening to
experts listening to my gut the the
feeling of the vice-president and and
really many others when we put it all
together
I very look if we didn't do what we did
at the time we could have lost more than
two million people I really believe that
I could show you charts of other places
that gave it a shot and then not doing
well and I would show it to you right
now I don't want to embarrass anybody
but they gave that a shot and it's an
automatic I mean everybody would say
let's do that until they sit down and
start thinking and we could have lost
more than two million people we could
have lost more than 2 min it could have
been much more than that by the way we
have one that says from one point six to
two point two but it could have really
been more than that but I looked at one
in particular one country in particular
that is using the herd mentality and not
working out very well now with all of
that being said we have to get back to
work we've will be crossing lines very
soon in many cases in some cases were
well on the way down in other cases were
right at the top and heading down we're
heading in the right direction I saw
some numbers from New Jersey which was
having a very tough time at starting
he's he's doing a terrific job that
governor phil phil murphy starting to
get some really good signs i looked at
some of the new york numbers they're
starting to get - they've been
devastated obviously but some really
good things are starting to happen so
if we would have done something
different first of all would have would
not have been sustainable you would have
had people they were been furious at you
and me and everybody up they it would
not have been sustainable because you
look at some of the hospitals as an
example a certain hospital right near
where I grew up in Queens and you had
body bags all over the floor of that
Hospital you know the one I'm talking
about
all over the floor of the hospital now
multiply that times twelve or fifteen
because that's the kind of numbers
you're talking about twelve or fifteen
and it would not have been it would not
have been a lot there would have been an
insurrection nobody would have nobody
would have understood that whereas right
now
nobody can be blamed and there is no
blame we're all in a situation that was
caused that should have been solved long
ago it could have been solved probably
very easily look it's a tough enemy but
probably very easily if a certain
country did what they should have done
and we're just starting to learn those
facts but what we did was the right
thing and what we did was the right
thing with that being said we want to
get back and we want to we're gonna be
opening up States they're being opened
by very capable people it's also point
of sale as they say in a different
business it's the point they'll be able
to look at that you know where the
testing is taking place we're gonna help
them with the testing we've developed
some tremendous tests over the last
little while and we're gonna work with
the state so we're gonna help them but
they know every inch of land in their
states I watched the governor of
Arkansas ASA you saw that he thought he
was terrific I watched the governor of
Oklahoma over the weekend being
interviewed he was terrific they've done
it a little bit differently and they've
done it tight and they've done it strong
and they were very prepared and they
have more beds than they need it and
that's a good thing but I've seen some
very very good things and I think you're
gonna have some very positive events
taking place over a very short period of
time and I think with that we'll see you
tomorrow but really this has been this
has been a situation where a lot of
great people have been involved
a lot of great decisions have been made
thank you all very much